even if you're a die-hard Fire Emblem
fan you could be forgiven for missing
out on the japan-only Fire Emblem Gaiden
which came out on the Famicom in 1992
the upcoming Fire Emblem echoes shadows
of Valente ax is based off guy dead but
don't call it a tile for tile scene for
scene remake the general story is the
same as are the main characters but
expect an expanded playable roster and
as you can see 3d model battles in the
same style as Awakening and faiths yes
it looks like a modern Fire Emblem game
just without the rock-paper-scissors
weapon triangle and gasp no romancing
what you're seeing is from our most
recent hands-on with echoes where we got
to check out one of the story battles
and the game's intriguing dungeon
crawling component the next time you'll
see echos footage will most likely be
for our review so give us a thumbs up
and subscribe to our channel if you want
to know our thoughts on the final
version what features would be in your
dream Fire Emblem game or does that game
exist already let us know in the
discussion below thanks for watching
[Music]
you a clever
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
not so fast where do you think you're
going don't you know whose holes these
is huh
but I thought this was the that's enough
Python there's no call to play a
trickery with our new recruits hey Lucas
you ginger stud you still draw breath
I was worried to say his dogs might have
punched your ticket to the boneyard
so this sack of guts here must be served
grandson yes he's the one mr. Clive
about yep better shake your tail
feathers he's been waiting for you oh
hey kid I almost forgot huh what is it
terrors roam these halls you'd best
tread carefully terrors what are
monsters like those doing in your
hideout well to be fair they technically
got here first we're just sort of
borrowing their catacombs Plus terror
spawning greater numbers the closer you
get to millas power counting them down
only makes room for new ones so we just
let them be why the long face dud don't
think you can handle a few creepy
crawlies because if not I don't know how
you're planning to fight for the
deliverance
I'm just j-pin yeah get going yeah oh
and hold your nose terrors stink great
their hideout is guarded by an army of
the Dead
these sprawling catacombs were built as
a resting place for Sophia's most
distinguished families but now their
halls are clogged with the stench of the
dead
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
allow me
[Music]
chuckling clever my mind
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
I've got this
[Music]
you
[Music]
konami fools
[Music]
is that elope rotten corpses who have
risen again as terrors
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'll never yield
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my prayers were answered
[Music]
[Applause]
never count Tobin out
[Music]
it's hard being this good
[Music]
[Music]
you're forming begone
[Music]
Oh